الفايروس المخلوي التنفسي ار اس بي يعتبر
شديد العدوى وغالبا بين التهابات شديده في
الجهاز التنفسي عند الاطفال والبالغين
بحسب خبراء الصحه ينتشر في الفتره الممتده
بين نوفمبر الى مارس حيث تعد الموسم
الفيروسي التقليدي وتدوم الاصابه به لمده
اسبوعين وفي بعض الحالات الحاده يضطر
المصاب الى الذهاب للمستشفى في بريطانيا
تشير الارقام الى ان هذا الفيروس هو السبب
الرئيسي لدخول الاطفال الى المستشفيات وفي
مصر اظهرت نتائج الاختبارات ان ثلاثه 73%
من الاطفال مصابون بالفيروس التنفسي
المحلوي كمان دراسه الهولنديه الجديده من
تاكيد ان هذا الفايروس هو السبب الرئيسي
الثاني بالوفاه خلال السنه الاولى من حياه
الطفل بعد المراريه وتصل الى ما بين 100
الى 200,000 طفل كل عام وحتى الان لا يوجد
علاج محدد للفيروس المخلويه التنفسي عند
الاطفال الاصحاء وبالتالي فان المساعده في
الحالات الحاده تكون بالذهاب الى
المستشفيات دي الملتحمه